They say Californians are
living the dream. - But things
aren't all back glamorous.
Nope.
We have our struggles.
It's no cakewalk.
No kidding.
For well over a century,
California was synonymous
with the American dream
of starting over and making it big.
By the early 1960s,
it had become the most
populous state in the country.
Now, California's population is declining
for the first time in recorded history.
Like New York, Illinois,
Pennsylvania, Ohio,
Michigan, and West Virginia,
California is losing a congressional seat,
another first for the Golden State.
The reasons behind California's decline
aren't hard to fathom.
According to Chief Executive magazine,
California is the worst
state to do business in,
a position at is held for
most of the list's existence.
California ranks eighth in combined state
and local tax burden,
forcing residents to
kick in an effective rate
of 11.5 percent of their
income just for being alive.
What do they get in return?
Public schools that rank
37th in the country,
insanely expensive housing
whose costs are inflated
by strict environmental
and land use regulations that
make it nearly impossible
to match supply with demand.
Rolling blackouts and power shortages
caused by environmental mandates
and poor utility governance,
an above average violent crime rate,
and the nation's highest poverty rate
with more than 36% of
California's residents
at or near the poverty level.
Governor Gavin Newsom faces a
recall election in the fall,
partly due to his hypocrisy
regarding his own
stringent lockdown rules.
Rather than grapple with
his state sinking status,
he's chosen instead to deny reality.
This remarkable, remarkable home
to more dreamers and doers than
any other part of the globe.
A smarter strategy might be to look
at the two biggest states
that are gaining in population
at California's expense.
Between 2010 and 2020, Florida's
population grew by 14.6 percent
and Texas' increased by 15.9 percent.
Their weather is awful
by California standards
and they lack its natural beauty,
but they ranked second and
first in business climate,
which means more opportunity,
even as their cost of living
is a fraction of California's.
Until and unless the Golden
State makes itself affordable
to dreamers and doers,
they'll keep heading
to other destinations.
As California loses a congressional seat,
Texas is picking up two.
And demographers predict
that it may become
the most populous state by 2045,
much sooner than was predicted
just a few years ago.
Texas may not have the
beaches, the forests,
the celebrities, or the glamour.
It'll just have the jobs, the companies,
the forward momentum, and the people.